شكرا صهيب اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
احييكم وهذه الساعه اخباريه جديده نخصص
معظمها لتغطيه تطورات الاحداث في السودان
البدايه بالعناوين
الجيش السوداني يؤكد موافقته على تمديد
الهدنه استجابه للمساعي السعوديه
الامريكيه
المبعوث الامامي للسودان يؤكد عدم وجود
مفاوضات مباشره بين طرفي النزاع في
السودان رغم الانفتاح على التفاوض
البنك المركزي السوداني يؤكد ان اموال
المذيعين في الجهاز المصرفي امنه ويعتبر
ان عمليات السرقه لا تؤثر على الودائع
وفي اخبارنا الاخرى ايضا
يستقبل انتقادات ترشحه للرئاسه في
الثمانين من عمره بالسخريه
[موسيقى]
بعد اعلان قوات الدعم السريع تمديد الهدنه
لمده 72 ساعه اكد الجيش السوداني موافقته
على التمديد استجابه للمساعي السعوديه
الامريكيه وذلك لدواعي انسانيه الطرفان
اتفقا على شيء واحد الا وهو ان الاخر يخرق
الهدنه فيقول الدعم السريع انه يتعرض
لهجوم بالطائرات فيما يقول الجيش انه رصد
نوايا الدعم السريع لمهاجمه بعض المواقع
في الاثناء تتواصل عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان خصوصا من بورسودان سواء برا او
جوا لكن في داخل السودان تحديدا في
العاصمه الخرطوم فالوضع اصبح ماساويا صحيا
وامنيا ومعيشيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما اسلفنا وافقت القوات المسلحه
السودانيه على تمديد الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه
على ان تبدا اعتبارا من انتهاء مده الهدنه
الحاليه وبحسب بيان الجيش فقد جاء ذلك
بناء على مساعد طلب الوساطه السعوديه
الامريكيه بحسب بيان الجيش السوداني اذا
اضاف انه على الرغم من رصده نوايا
المتمردين بمحاوله الهجوم على بعض المواقع
الا انه يامل في ان يلتزم المتمردون
بمتطلبات تنفيذ الهدنه وقد اكدت القوات
المسلحه السودانيه على جاهزيتها التامه
للتعامل مع اي خروقات السيطره كامله على
كل الولايات 17 والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غربوفان
غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها متغير
ومتغير الاخير الذي تمثل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها قيد الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس صحيحا
قبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع تمديد
اجل الهدنه الانسانيه الاثنتين وسبعين
ساعه اعتبارا من منتصف الليله من اجل فتح
الممرات الانسانيه وتسهيل حركه المواطنين
والمقيمين وقد جددت قوات الدعم السريع في
بيان نشرته على صفحتها الرسميه في تويتر
جددت التزامها الصارم بالهدنه الانسانيه
والوقف الكامل لاطلاق النار وقال الدعم
السريع انه تصدى لهجمات متكرره من الجيش
خلال ايام الهدنه
[موسيقى]
في الاطراف وتضرب وتحوم حول مواقع الدعم
السريع ما يسمع من رصاص ومضادات الدعم
السريعه الارضيه تتصدى لهجوم طيران لكن
على ارض الواقع في ولايه الخرطوم في كل
مدنها ثلاثه لا توجد قوات مشاه للجيش او
قوات تتحرك من مكان الى مكان للجيش هذه
مزال حسمت من الايام لا يوجد تحرك للجيش
داخل ولايه الخرطوم
اعلنت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عن
ارسالها اول شحنه مساعدات انسانيه من
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الى بورتسودان
وقالت اللجنه في بيان ان الشحنه المرسله
مؤلفه من ثمانيه اطنان من المعدات
الجراحيه لدعم مستشفيات السودان ومتطوعي
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني بالاضافه
الى مواد تخدير وادوات تضميض ولوازم خياطه
الجروح وغير ذلك من المعدات الجراحيه التي
يمكن ان تستخدم لعلاج الاف الاشخاص من
الذين اصيبوا بجروحه جراء الاشتباكات في
السودان
بعد الرابع عشر من ابريل لم يتمكن احد من
الحصول على الدعم الطبي في البلاد التي هي
في امس الحاجه اليها نامل ان تنتقل هذه
المساعدات سريعا من بورتسودان الى
المستشفيات وهذا يتطلب احترام كلا
الجانبين وقف اطلاق النار حتى نتمكن مع
زملائنا من الهلال الاحمر السوداني من
توصيل هذه المواد في اسرع وقت ممكن الى
المستشفيات
عرض افراد من قوات الدعم السريعه اسلحه
ثقيله قالوا انهم وجدوها داخل حاويه بمنزل
رئيس وزراء السودان الاسبق الصادق المهدي
مشيرين الى ان من بين الاسلحه المعروضه
بندقيه استخدمت في قنص افراد منهم بمبنى
الاذاعه على حد قولهم
امامكم منها الاربجي الدوشكا
القناصات بعض الاسلحه والزفائر والمتفجرات
ومنها الجرانيتات وبعض الاسلحه الصغيره
لقد تم الاستيلاء عليها والغبط في بيت
الصيد الصادق المهدي بعد الحصول على تلك
القناص الذي كان يستهدف القوه داخل
الاذاعه بهذه القناصه من هذه المنوره فوق
في سطح العالي لقد استهدف اثنين جروحه من
قواتنا الباسله وقد تم العثور عليه من قبل
القناص فاداهم تلك المنزل
ربنا وفقنا لقد وجدنا هذه امامكم موجوده
بالاسلحه المتوفره هذه كل هذه الاسلحه
والزخائر منها اسلحه الزخارج ثقيله
واسلحه كبيره
وهذه هي القوه امامكم كما ترون
فقد تم الاشترا للسلاح كما ذكرنا ولم تقوم
في خسائر ولم تكن في ارواح فهذا استهداف
لقواتنا وهذا لا يمكن ان يكون موجوده في
بيت مسؤول او موجود في بيت غايد فهذه
اسلحه صغيره ربما تكون موجوده في القيادات
العسكريه
الحمايه الشخصيه هنا لحمايه احزاب وانما
هذه استهداف عسكري
اظهر مقطع فيديو ونشرته وكاله رويترز
اشخاصا يدخلون ويخرجون من مبنى مصرف
السلام في السوق الشعبي في ام درمان غرب
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
اهلا بك سالم اقل من ثلاث ساعات لدخول
الهدنه المفترضه الجديده بين الطرفين كيف
يبدو الوضع على الارض هل هناك محاولات رغم
الهدنه الموجوده اصلا للاستفاده من
الساعات المتبقيه لتحسين المواقع
للمشاهدين بالنسبه للوضع ميدانيا الان
الشوارع الدخاليه هنا في الخرطوم من
الماره وكذلك من المواطنين وهذا معتاد
عليه المواطنون منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات
بعدم الحركه ليلا بالنسبه للمواطنين لان
ذلك فيه خطوره يضاف الى ذلك موضوع عمليات
النهب والسلبه التي بات يشكو بها
المواطنين
الخرطوم تحديدا هذه الامور اصبحت كثيره
جدا شكاوى المواطنين من كثره عمليات النهب
والسلب تصوير بعض المواطنين ايضا
للفيديوهات يتهمون بها قوات الدعم السريع
بانها هي من تقوم بعمليه النهو السلب او
ان هنالك ايضا عصابات اخرى تقوم بهذه
العمليات دون ان تجد رابعا تكررت هذه
الامور في الفتره الماضيه وربما هذا ما
يشكل هاجسا للعديد من سكان العاصمه
الخرطوم خاصه بعد عمليات النهب والسرقه
التي تمت لي المنطقه الصناعيه في مدينه
بحري وسوق بحري وكذلك سوق سعد اليسرى كلها
اسواق موجوده في مدينه بحري تعرضت للنهو
والسرقه وكذلك المصانع كل هذه الامور تجعل
المواطن في هذا التوقيت يكون الملتزما
بيته ويغلق عليه بابه طيب اما في ساعات
النهار مثلا كيف يتصرف المواطن كيف يستطيع
تامين حاجياته
هناك اجتهاد من المواطنين دائما في الصباح
بالخروج بحثا عن احتياجاتهم الضروريه التي
يحتاجون اليها ويبحثوا عن الطرق الامنه
البعيده عن انتشار هذه القوات حتى لا يكون
هنالك اشتباك مع هذه القوات او تتعرض لهم
باي شكل من الاشكال
يحرص المواطنين على الابتعاد تماما عن
المناطق التي توجد بها الاسلحه والذخائر
او تبادل اغلاق النار او حتى اي نوع من
انواع الاشتباكات بعض الطرق التي عرفها
المواطنين يمرون عبر هذه الطرق لتكون اكثر
يبحثون عن حاجياتهم لكن شكاوى المواطنين
متكرره فيما يتعلق بالامداد الغذائي وكذلك
فيما يتعلق كذلك
الخدمات الاخرى فيما يتعلق بالمياه
والكهرباء وكذلك الموضوع الصحي كذلك كل
هذه الامور نجد فيها الشكاوى تتكرر دائما
وبالتالي هذا ما يتوقع له ان يطول سالم
صحيح الموضوع الذي يتعلق خاصه بمياه الشرب
واحده من الامور المؤرقه حقيقه لسكان
مدينه بحري ويضاف اليها احياء اخرى من
الخرطوم واحياء اخرى من ام درمان واحده من
الامور التي تشكل
عائقا وعبئا ثقيلا على ساكن هذه المناطق
دفعا العديد منهم الخروج من هذه المناطق
بحثا عن مناطق توجد بها مياه شرب
وهذا اصبح هو الحد الادنى ان يتحصلوا على
مياه للشرب دعك من بقيه الاحتياجات الاخرى
دفعه ايضا بعض المواطنين في مدينه بحر
شاهدنا هذا الامر الى شرب مياه غير صالحه
للشرب اصلا بتسخينها فقط ومن ثم شرب هذه
المياه كل هذه الامور تجعل الموضوع الذي
يتعلق بالخدمات فيما يتعلق ايضا بتذبذب
خدمه الكهرباء وانقطاع هتام في مناطق منذ
بدا هذه الاشتباكات ونحن الان في الاسبوع
الثالث على التوالي ما الذي يمكن ان نضيفه
على صعيد الوسطات وموقف الجيش وك ذلك موقف
الدعم السريع منها
كان على الصعيد الخارجي او على الصعيد
الداخلي من القوه المحليه المدنيه
ما يفهم من البيانات التي تتعلق
بموضوع الوساطات وغيرها يمكن ان تربط كذلك
بالبيانات الصادره من الطرفين
سواء البيانات الصادره من القوات المسلحه
السودانيه او حتى البيانات التي تصدر عن
الدعم السريع هذه البيانات توحي بان هنالك
ربما نقول تحشيد على مستوى عالي جدا يجعل
مساله المفاوضات بعيده المنال بالنظر لهذه
البيانات البيانات التي تتكرر من تبادل
الاتهامات اخر البيانات الصادره وهو بيان
صادر من الجيش السوداني تحدث عن اتهامه
لهذه الميليشيا بحسب وصف القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه وصفت ان هذه الميليشيا
المتمرده قامت بمجموعه من العمليات التي
هي عمليات النهب والسرقه وكذلك اتهمت فيها
ايضا الدعم السريع بانها دائما تتحرك في
ان الهدنه وانا هي من تخترق هذه الهدنه
كذلك وبعد ذلك تحدث هذا البيان عن نجاح
للقوات المسلحه في تكبيدها خسائر في شمال
بحري واسرت منهم عددا كبيرا كانوا بصدد
الهروب كذلك ايضا تحدث هذا البيان عن فشل
لمخططات قاعده المتمردين في الاستيلاء على
السلطه بالقوه وانه لجاوا الى اتباع سياسه
الارض المحروقه وذلك بحرق ونهب المزيد من
البنوك المحلات التجاريه لوجود التخريب كل
هذه الامور التي ذكرت في هذا البيان
وهنالك ايضا بيان مضاد ورد ايضا على هذا
البيان يفهم من هذه البيانات بلغه هذه
البيانات ان الامر في تصعيد وانه يصعب ان
يكون في هذا الوضع موضوع حوار خاصه بعد
البيانات التي تحدثت في الجيش عن انه لابد
ان يحسم هذا التمرد ومن ثم بعد ذلك ينظر
في العمليه السياسيه الجاريه الان في
البلاد شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من الخرطوم
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعت المرسى
المواطنين السكان في المنطقه مثل الشمبا
ومناطق المجاوره من هنا مباشره من النيل
شيلوا مويه بتاعت شرب شيلوها من النيل ومن
هنا من المرسى وانت ماشي فالناس بتعاني
جدعاني شديد جدعاني تتحرك
[موسيقى]
قوات الاحتياط المركزي جنوب الخرطوم معركه
كلاميه بين الشرطه وقوات الدعم السريعه
التي اتهمت الشرطه بالوقوف طرفا في الصراع
في المقابل اكدت الشرطه ان الاحتياطيه
المركزيه قوه تابعه لها تعمل على تامين
الاسواق وممتلكات المواطنين وعلى ضبط اي
حاله فيلات امنيه
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي السودانيه
هي قوه شرطيه تم انشاؤها عام 1990 وهي من
الادارات المهمه بقوات الشرطه وتقع
قيادتها بالكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم وتنتشر في
العاصمه والولايات تم تدريب عناصرها
للقيام بعمليات المسلحه وشاركت قبل اعوام
في عمليات قتاليه مع الجيش في ولايات
دارفور وجنوب كردفان والنيل الازرق وشرق
السودان سلاحها اقرب لسلاح الجيش وبها فرق
عمليات خاصه تتدرب على يد القوات الخاصه
بالقوات المسلحه بدات الانتشار يوم السبت
بجنوب الخرطوم على ان يتوالى نزولها
لمناطق اخرى من العاصمه هذه القوات خاضعه
لعقوبات امريكيه منذ مارس من عام 2022
بتهمه استخدام القوه المفرطه ضد محتجين في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
ومع اعلان الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيوس ارسال موفد او مسؤول كبير الى
السودان
متحدثا عن وضع وصفه بغير المسبوق نتحدث
الى الصحافه محمد اسحاق عثمان من الخرطوم
بحري ينضم الينا الان اهلا بك معنا محمد
اين هي ابرز المواقع التي انتشرت فيها
الشرطه وهل هي قادره على الاستمرار في
الانتشار وبالتالي القيام بمهامها في بعض
مناطق العاصمه
مرحبا مساء الخير طاهر الوضع الان لا يبعد
كثيرا الوضع الذي كان يتحدث عنه قبل قليل
زميل الهاشمي نحن هنا في منطقه بحري في
اقصى الشمال منطقه جسر الحلفاء والاحياء
التي
بجوار جسر الحلفه
يلزم المكان تكاد الشوارع تكون خاليه او
شبه خاليه الجميع تعود طاهر في فتره
المساء منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات ان
يلزموا منازلهم لان لا تكثر في فتره
المساء مسائل السلب والمهب هذه العصابات
التي تجوب
التي
الشرطه نعم
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي وصلت الى هذه
المنطقه وكان
هناك عمل كبير قامت به ولكن سرعان ايضا ما
تراجعت هذه الالتكازات الان لا نراها غير
موجوده الان لا لا شرطه ولا ولا جيش ولا
حتى ارتكازات للدعم السريع وهذا شجع هذه
الجماعات التي تعمل على السلب والنهب على
التحرك خاصه فيها مسيطره عليها يعني لا
الشرطه ولا الاحتياطي المركزي ولا الجيش
انه عندما نتحدث عن مناطق العاصمه
نعم ربما تكون في احياء بحري بعض الاحياء
المتقدمه كانت هذه الاستكازات
يتحكم فيها قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
الشمبات والشعبيه وحله حمد والاحياء التي
هي اقرب الى يسرى ولكن في اقصى الشمال او
الشمال جسر الحلفايه هذه المنطقه التي
احدثك منها الان كانت هناك بعض
ما جاءت كانت هناك بعض
الارتكازات في هذه المنطقه جوار الحلفايه
ولكن الان لا الحظ هذا الوجود الشرا الجيش
كما تحدثنا في نشاط سابقه طاهر اقام
بالتنشيط وعمليات التنشيط في هذه المنطقه
ربما انتهت عمليات التنشيط
يعني بالقرب من موعد اذان المغرب وكانت
عمليات
جابت كل احياء هذه او جابت كل هذه الاحياء
التي هي تجاور جسر الحلفايه بعد ذلك
تشرح لنا يعني قدر استطاعتك وقدر المتوفر
من المعلومات والمشاهدات كيف بيكون الوضع
لما الجيش بيكون عم بينشط وقوات الدعم
السريع تسيطر على شوارع وجسور بعينها
نعم في بعض المعركه التي دارت في جسر
الحلفايه بالامس وكانت معركه شرسه جدا
وكانت يعني فيها كثير من الكر والفر الذي
شاهدناه من خلال هذه الفتره وشهد السكان
في هذه المنطقه لحظات وساعات اصيله جدا
بعد ذلك سيطر الجيش على هذا الجسم جسر
الحلفايه ووضع بعض الارتكازات وجاء اليوم
ليعيد مساله التنشيط ارتال من السيارات
العسكريه حامله الجنود طافه اليوم شوارع
هذه الاحياء داخل الاحياء انتشار ايضا
شاهدنا جنود على ارجلهم واخرين هم يمتطون
هذه السيارات العسكريه نعم
بهذا القدر نعود لك في نشاط لاحقه ان شاء
الله محمد اسحاق عثمان الصحفي من الخرطوم
بحري وبيان المتحدث باسم الامين العام
الامم المتحده يقول الان انه في ضوء
الازمه الانسانيه المتفاقمه في السودان
سترسل المنظمه منسق الاغاثه في حالات
الطوارئ مارتن جرافيث الى المنطقه على
الفور
بس
طلع الممثل الخاص للامين العام لرئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده المتكامله للمساعده
الانتقاليه في السودان
قال انه لا توجد الى الان مفاوضات مباشره
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
نستمع الى ما قاله ومبعوث الامم المتحده
الى السودان
ليس هناك مفاوضات مباشره
هناك تحذيرات
لمحادثه
او
للتخدير موحدسه
بين الجانبين
[موسيقى]
تشتغل مباشره
مع الجهتين اخنان وساند هذه الجهود انا
شخصيا كمان باتصال مباشر مع جانبين
فان شاء الله
سنرتب باقرب وقت ممكن
لقاء مباشر بين ممثلين
القوات المسلحه والام السريع كي نصل الى
اكثر من هدنه الى وقف اطلاق نار منظم اكثر
باليه مراقبه
حضر المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف على حسابه في تويتر
من انتشار المواجهات العرقيه في البلاد في
ظل احتدام الاقتتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع مشددا على ان استمرار الحرب سيضعف
الدوره المدني تلقائيا ويتحول لدور هامشي
مشيرا الى ان الموقف المدني الديمقراطي
يجب ان يكون بالضغط لوقف الحرب وتكوين
جبهه مدنيه ديمقراطيه واسعه مطالبا بجيش
واحد يتم الوصول اليه بالاتفاق على خطه
شامله للاصلاح الامني والعسكري تتضمن
تنفيذ الترتيبات الامنيه المنصوص عليها في
اتفاق جبال السلام ودمج الدعم سريع في
القوات المسلحه
معنا من باريس عضو الهيئه القياديه بحزب
المسار الوطنيه عاصم جميل اهلا بكم معنا
استاذ عاصم هل تتوقعون انفراجه حقيقيه في
الهدنه الجديده التي من المفترض ان تبدا
الليله
نعم نتوقع ذلك
بحسب ما تفسير الامور
هذه
الهدنه طبعا هناك محاولات متكرره بين
الجانبين ولكن نلاحظ عمليات التمشيط التي
يقوم بها الجيش ما زالت مستمره وموضوع
التفاوض نفسه اعتقد ان انا استمعت الى
تصريح المتحدث الامريكي وتصريح
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه الذين
ذكرتهما من قبل وانا اعتقد انهما
اثنين يعني يخطئان في تقدير الموازين
لعلهما
بحيث انه التفاوض نفسه يعني ورقه التفاوض
هذه لا اعرف كيف
يصرون على تقديمها
وليس في الحقيقه هناك تكافؤ في القوى وفي
ميزان ميزان الحرب هذه نقطه النقطه
الثانيه هي مساله الديمقراطيه التي يتحدث
عنها المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه الذي
ذكرتموه حضرتكم في قناتكم المفضله وانا
استغرب عن كيف ان الذي
يعني كان مشاركا اساسيا في العمليه التي
تعقدت وادت الى الحرب واوقعت هذه
المجازر في في السودان وحمام الدم الذي
حصل الان بتزيينه للقوى العسكريه في
الفرقه المتمرده من الدعم السريع
للاستيلاء على السلطه ثم ياتون من بعد ذلك
للحديث عن العمليه السلميه والعمليه
الديمقراطيه نعتقد ان هؤلاء الساس الذين
جربوا
المجرب وفشله حتى وقعت الحرب عليهم ان
يصمتوا الان وان يتركوا المساحه للوطنين
الذين يريدون بناء الدوله نحن في ذات
الوقت نثمن جهود مجموعات من الوطنيين
الذين اثبتوا في هذه المرحله الخطيره التي
يمر بها السودان مدى وطنيتهم مدى تمسكم
بقضايا حقيقيه يحاولون معالجه وليس الامر
فقط يعني مزايده سياسيه وحشد للشعب الشعب
الان انت تلوم يعني شخصيه سياسيه وكانها
هي السبب في ما الت اليه الامور بين
المتحاربين العسكريين ومن ثم هو شخصيه
يعني ليست طارئه نتجت بناء على ثوره قام
بها الشعب السوداني وكان يؤيدها واوصلها
الى ما وصل اليه باختيار القوات المسلحه
ايضا للتفاوض معهم كقوه مدنيه الان تعيب
عليهم ما تسميه قله الوط نيه
احسنت باختيارك فعل الماضي في قوله كانوا
يؤيدونهم بالنسبه لشباب الثوره ونحن كنا
مشاركون في الثوره ايضا والان
كان فعل ماضي ناقص ليدل على فتره زمنيه
ماضيه وليس الانتهاء الدور
وانا اؤكد لك ان الدعم الذي كانوا يحظون
به في مرحله من المراحل الشعبي لانه الشعب
السوداني
شعب يحب وطنه وشعب يسعى بالخير لوطي يعني
يريد ان يحقق الديموقراطيه والسلام والامن
والمدنيه وفي بالتالي وثقوا في هؤلاء
الساسه الذين اوردوا البلد موارد الهلاك
والان هم هؤلاء الشباب حتى شباب الثوره
وشباب الشعب السوداني
وكافه اطياف الشعب السوداني قاطبه واعين
تماما لتصرفات هؤلاء وهذا ليس حديثي انا
انا عندما اتحدث بهذا الامر
هو دعا الى تكوين جبهه مدنيه ديمقراطيه
واسعه لماذا لا تضمكم جميعا يعني لا افهم
ما سبب الخلاف
هذا ما كنا ندعو اليه اخي الكريم وهذا كان
تدعو اليه القوى العسكريه ولكنهم كانوا
يصرون على تضييق الماعون السياسي ويصيرون
على تمرير اجندتهم التي يعلمون تماما ان
الشعب السوداني بوعيه وبطبيعته الوطنيه
وانتمائه لوطنه سيرفضه وبالتالي هم يرفضون
للانتخابات ونحن اخبرناهم كثير في كثير من
المرات انه بيننا وبينهم صناديق الاقتراع
هذه هي اللغه الحضاريه المدنيه التي نحن
نسعى اليها كقوه سياسيه في السودان
انتخابات عارضه لانتخابات ولا تسليم
للسلطه بعد ولا كل ما كان يريدون الاتفاق
عليه لم يكن يتم اصلا
صحيح بسبب التعنت السياسي في المواقف بسبب
تضييق معون المشاركه بسبب حتى اقصاء
الشباب انفسهم الذين يعني استاذي الكريم
من الذي فضل الاعتصام هذا تساؤل يتساءل هو
كثير من شباب السودان
الوطنيين الحاذبين على امر الثوره وعلى
امر البلاد عندما راينا فيديوهات فض
الاعتصام راينا فيديوهات الدعم السريع
الان هذه الحرب بين الدعم السريع وبين
الجيش نسوا عمليه فضل الاعتصام في رمشه
رمشه عين ونسوا الجثث التي كانت مكدسه في
مستشفى التميز التي لا زالت استاذي لا
زالت مقدسه في مستشفى التميز حتى يومي
ويومك هذا ونسوا كل هذه الاشياء وينشغلوا
بالسلطه وبتقسيم الكيكه وبتمرير الاجنده
ايضا عن كل ذلك ولكن البعض يقول انه يعني
على الاقل لك ان يعني تلوم ولو بشكل جزئي
الجانب العسكري على ما قالت اليه الامور
سياسيه بما انه
يتهم بانه طرف معرقل ولا ان يعني ترمي
الكره كلها بملعب القوه المدنيه لان
الطرفين المتحاربين الان
عسكريان وبالتالي لابد وان يتحمل الجيش
ايضا جزءا من المسؤوليه في مساله اليه
الامور خاصه يعني مع التفرقه مع انه جيش
وطني ويجب على كل الوقوف معه ولكن على
الاقل قد اتفق معك في ذلك ولكن على الاقل
حمله جزءا من المسؤوليه فيما يتعلق بما
الت اليه الامور السياسيا ما رايك
بالطبع يتحمل الجيش القوات المسلحه هي
مؤسسه وطنيه منوط بها حمايه البلد تتحمل
المسؤوليه في التراخي نفسه الذي طبعا
انشاء قوات الدعم السريع في الاصل كانت
واحده من اخطاء النظام السابق التي يعني
جنى بها على السودان واوصلنا بها الى هذه
الحرب هذا متفق عليه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير عندما بدا في
يعني تكوين هذه القوات الحكماء من اهل
السودان وبينهم الامام الصادق المهدي الذي
يهاجم منزله الان من قبل هذه القوات حذر
من وجود قوه كهذه في في ارض الواقع هذا
نحن متفقون عليه تماما ان انشاء الدعم
السريع من اساسه كان خطا ثم بعد ذلك ت
تحمل عسكريه مسؤوليه يعني تباطؤه في حسم
هذا الامر اذا كان هناك اصلا يعني معرفه
بان هناك هذه القوه يمكن ان تتمرد كان يجب
حسمها من البدايه هل انت معي استاذي انا
معك تفضل قبل ان تتغول
هذه هذه القوه كان من الاساس انشائها كان
خاطئه طيب نحن وعقدت المشهد السياسي نحن
متفقون جميعا على ذلك الان بعد ان اعلنت
تمردها ووقفت مع الجيش ناتي وندافع عنها
ونخرج لها المبررات ام نسعى
للرجوع بسرعه الى العمليه السياسيه
والعمليه السلميه من قبل الوطنيين ما الذي
يدفعهم الى ذلك لانه عندهم مخاوف من سيطره
حركات اسلاميه على بعض قيادات الجيش وعلى
تحريك يعني على تجير القرار العسكري للجيش
لصالح
احتماليه رغبه البعض في اعاده رموز من
النظام السابق ما رايك
نعم هذه مخاوف موجوده ومشروعه اي مخاوف
على البلاد في امنها الوطني وفي كينونتها
وهويتها هذه من حقهم ان يتحفظوا على ذلك
ولكن لا يمكن ان نحكم على المؤسسه
العسكريه قاطبه بالفشل
والتفكيك بمجرد دعوه ان الحركه الاسلاميه
او الاخوانيون
الجهه الفلانيه تسيطر عليها هذه ستقطع
سنشرك في الحوار تبقى معنا سنشرك في
الحوار عروه الصادق عضو حزب الامه القومي
من الخرطوم اهلا بك معنا استاذ ما رايك
بما سمعت اليه
تحياتي اخي طاهر وحيا ضيفك الكريم وحياه
مشاهدات ومشاهدي العربيه
اقول ان الحديث مطلقا صحيح ان
الحديث عن تفكيك الجيش كبيره من الكبائر
ولكن ضيفك هل هنالك من قال بتفكيك المؤسسه
العسكريه السودانيه لم يرد ولا سطر
بادبيات القوه السياسيه المدنيه في
السودان ولا سطر واحد عن تفكيك القوات
المسلحه السودانيه هذه المؤسسه مبنيه من
عرق ودم ودموع الشعب السوداني كيف لنا ان
نفكها كيف ترد على هذه النقطه تحديدا لو
تكرمت
نعم
ارد عليها اخي الكريم بانه طبعا لا يمكن
ان يكتب في
الوثائق والدساتير انه تفكك المؤسسه
العسكريه لانه مؤسسه العسكريه اقوى من انه
تؤتى يؤتى اليها من هذا الباب ولكن هذه
المحاولات يا استاذي انت وظيفك الكريم
يعني معلومه حتى للسودانيين البسطاء
محاولات التدخل محاولات الاجنده التي يجب
يحاول بعض السياسيين فرضها في العمليه
السياسيه يعني اكثر من انك تهاجم القوات
المسلحه وتهاجم قائد القوات المسلحه في
مهجعه كيف تريد ان ان تفكك الجيش اكثر من
ذلك كون من كونك تفكر في مواجهه القوات
المسلحه وازاحه قادته والجلوس على كرسي
السلطه بالقوه ماذا نسمي هذا واذا كان
المدنيون ما كتبوا ذلك لماذا لا يخرج الان
ويبين مواقفهم كموقف هذا في دعمهم للقوات
المسلحه كمؤسسه وطنيه عسكريه
ويعني مواجهتهم للدعم السريع بانه لابد ان
يحسم وان يستسلم بقيه قواته وان نعود
للعمليه السلميه لماذا لا يقولون ذلك
وصلت النقطه استاذ عروه
نعم
الحديث ايضا يريد جرنا الى منطقه المنطقه
المنطقه المعوج انت لست معي فانت ضدي نحن
لسنا ضد القوات المسلحه السودانيه ولن نقف
يوم وظللت اردد حتى على شاشتكم لو قدر لي
ان احمل سلاح في وطني ساحمله خلف القوات
المسلحه السودانيه ولن احمله خلف اي تكوين
اخر لا حركات مسلحه ولا دعم سريع ولا سوى
هذه
مفرقه لدى كثير من السودان السودانيات
ولكن ما هي القوات المسلحه التي نريدها
القوات المسلحه المهنيه المنضبطه التي اقر
حتى جنرالاتها بانها تحتاج الى اصلاح
وهنالك من قال باعاده هيكله وهنالك من قال
باعاده تكوين
بلد دخل في حاله حرب يعني اتى لا يمكن ان
تفصل جيشا على مقاسك الان او على مقاس
القوى المدنيه التي تريد جيشا مختلفا الان
دخلتم في حرب والبعض يقول بانه من حيث
المبدا
يجب الوقوف الى جانب الجيش حتى انتهاء هذه
المعركه لانه يعني هو عماد البلد الاساسي
عسكريا وان فقدتم الجيش وتفككت وانقسم
فقدتم يعني جزءا اساسيا من هيبه الدوله
ومن وجودها ربما ومن وحدتها ربما
صدقت اخي بركه صدقت اخي الطاهر هذه
الاحاديث يمكن ان تقال في حال ان اتخذنا
موقف مضر بالقوات المسلحه موقفنا الان هو
الموقف الصحيح وهو الوقوف ضد الحرب
ايا كانت منابعها
وحديثنا للجنرالات وسعينا الان الذي ظل ظل
الجنرال يرفضانه اذا كان من قبل قياده
الدعم السريع او قياده الجيش الان ركنا
اليه اليوم انا اتحدث معك الحمد لله تمت
الاستجابه لتمديد هدنه
بجنه
باجتهاداتنا لانه ما قال احدهم قال سنحسم
الامر
سنستقله ونقدمه للعداله هذه الامور معروف
في السودان طوال السنوات التمرد والتمرد
لم يكن
الوهله الاولى ولا الثانيه لدينا تيار
مريضه عشناها وكلها انتهت الى صلح بحوار
وجلوس وهذا المطلوب ايضا اعود الى من حيث
المبدا بين قوسين انه هذا الكلام يعني
محاوله هروب من اتخاذ موقف حقيقي صادق
بالنسبه الى البعض
بضروره تاييد الجيش يعني نقول لا للحرب
ويعني نعفي انفسنا من الطرفين
شخصي وكثيرون حينما كانت المعركه في
الفشقه اول من وضعنا تمامنا حاضرين امام
قياده الفرقه الخارجيه امام السيده الفريق
وقتها خالد الشامي والسيد صبير قائد
الاستخبارات كان هذا الموقف الان الموقف
قتال ابناء جلدتنا بسلاحنا لا يمكن ان نقف
في صف احدهما ضد الاخر موقفنا ان
يقول اصلحوا بينهما حتى الموقف
استاذ عاصم استاذ عاصم
ده الموقف الوطني والديني
الان طبعا الشعار لكل من يريد ان لا يبين
انه موقفه ليس مع القوات المسلحه هو شعار
لا للحرب يا استاذي الفاضل يا اساتذتي
نحن لسنا يعني تقصد من يؤيد قوات الدعم
السريع ولا يريد ان يقولها علانيه يقول لا
للحرب
بالضبط ونحن الان في مرحله يا استاذي لنكن
وطنيه لنكن وطنيه نحن الان لا نفكر من اجل
المصالح الشخصيه ولا من اجل الاحزاب نحن
نفكر من اجل الشعب السوداني الذي يعيش تحت
القصف وتحت الدانات وتسهيل دماغه في
الشوارع نحن الان مساله الحرب هو مع
الجاهز مع الجيش واضح واضح يقول لك مع
الجيش وانا سالته اذا ما كنت انضميت لالنا
سالته اسئله ايضا مضاده له ولتوجهاته
والان افعل الامر نفسه معك ولكن هو صار
قال انا مع الجيش الان انت تقول يجب ان
تحدد خيارك
لا يمكن ان انا بقول لك موقفي مع الجيش في
حاله العدوان الخارجي ولكن لم اقف مع
الجيش في في مقاتلته لاخواننا في حركات
الكفاح المسلح ولم اقف مع الجيش عند حرب
الجنوب كنا نقول باننا يجب ان ندعى بينه
من الصعب
هذا ما يصاب اليه انا اقول لك حقائق او
قائد
اتفضل اليه اخي طاهر هذا ما سيصار اليه
العقل والتجربه
والمنطق يقول بان نتوسط بين ابناء السودان
وبين بني جلدتنا لخفض السلاح بينهما وليس
لتاليبا او تحشيد راي على الاخر فالمصير
حينئذ سيكون تمزيق للوطن وتمزيق للحمه
الوطنيه وتفعيل
فيها كافه الجيوش وهو ما قلنا به في نصوص
ما وفي اتفاقاتنا ونسعى اليه
والنسعى الى اصلاحها من داخل جنرالات
القوات المسلحه وعبر خبراء فنيون لا مدخل
للمزايده السياسيه فيها تمام وبالتالي لا
تتخذ لماذا لا تتخذون موقفا وسطيا استاذ
عاصم جميل كالكلام الذي استمعنا اليه من
الاستاذ عروه حتى لا توزعوا صكوكا في
الوطنيه على زملائكم على اشقائكم في الوطن
والله نحن نتمنى ان يكون كل القوى الوطنيه
على قد رجل واحد هذه هذا ما نتمناه في
الحقيقه ولكن للاسف الشديد طبعا الاحزاب
الطائفيه في السودان
وبعض البيوتات التي يعني
تتقلب مواقفها وفقا لمصالحها الشخصيه طبعا
هذه الامور اصبحت واضحه لعموم الشعب
السوداني نحن عندنا اتصال بالقواعد في
الوطن الناس البسيطين العاديين لانه
السودان منذ بدايه منذ
الاستقلال ومنذ ما قبل الاستقلال كان ضحيه
لانه السياسه فيه يتلاعب بها النخط طبعا
والنخب للاسف الشديد في بعض المواقف تكون
حساباتهم في مصالحهم الاجتماعيه ومصالحهم
الشخصيه اكبر من اهمهم الوطن وهذه مشكله
حقيقيه هذه المشكله تحدث عنها الخبراء في
السودان وتحدث تحدث عنها مراكز البحوث
لكن نحن الان
بصدد حرب باختصار نحن الان بصدد يا اخي
منعطف تاريخي لم تحدث هذا لم يحدث هذا
الامر لم يحتل الخرطوم منذ الاستغلال يعني
نحن الان امام مجموعات همجيه مسلحه تحتل
العاصمه يحاربها جيش قومي الموضوع بهذه
البساطه نقعد نقول لا للحرب
ندعو في المجتمع الدولي لحلحله مشاكلنا
ونجري للسفارات ونجري للاليه الرباعيه
والخماسيه ونجري لي الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه ونحن نقدر كل الجهود ولكن هذه
مشكلتنا نحن كسودانيين كسودانيين وطنيين
واجب الوطني للوقوف اولا كما تريد ان تقول
معلش حاولت ان اختصر لانه انتهى وقتنا
نهائيا شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عاصم جميل
كلمه اخيره باختصار انتهى وقت عروات تفضل
الكلمه الاخيره هي ان
سيقودنا الى
شاشتكم سناتي يوما ان هنالك صلح ابر بين
الجنرالين وان الجيش ادمج في قناه قوه
مسلحه واحده قوه والحركات المسلحه والدعم
السريع وان الاستقرار لن يكون الا على ذلك
ورهاننا حينئذ سيكون على القوات المسلحه
الموحده شكرا جزيلا لك عروه صادق الامه
القومي من الخرطوم شكرا ايضا لعاصم جميل
العضو الهيئه القياديه بحزب المسار الوطني
من باريس تحياتي اليكما
في القاهره تكثر المبادرات الفرديه التي
يقوم بها المصريون لمسانده السودانيين
ودعمهم ولكن ماذا عن منظمات المجتمع
المدني حتى الان الاعداد التي جاءت الى
مصر لم تشكل مشكله كبيره نظرا لان
السودانيين القادمين قادرون على التملك او
الاستئجار او المبيت عند معارفهم هناك
خشيه من نزوح المزيد من السودانيين مما
سيستلزم تدخلات سريعه من الجمعيات
والمنظمات المعنيه
الكثير من السودانيين الواصلين للقاهره
يملكون عقارات او القدره على استئجار
الشقق ومن لا يجد مثل بلال فيستضيفه
الاقارب والاصدقاء اه طبعا ولو ما وصلت
طوال يعني اول ما رنيت التليفون رنيت على
صاحبي وهم لا يعني مش مصدقين اول مادهم
على طول والله اللي هو قاعد مع اخويا
والله يا صاحبي وربنا يشكره وربنا يشكره
يشكر مع توم
واسماعيل برضو والله دي لاخواتني ولا قاعد
دلوقتي استقبلني والله لكن في ناس ما
عندهمش في ناس صعبه في ناس هيجوا هيكون
معاهم مثلا حاجه اول شهر اول شهرين طب
وبعدين اذا امتدت الازمه هيكون وضعهم ايه
في في المجتمع المصري في مصابين في مرضى
يعني في لا الموضوع كبير يعني اكبر من
مجرد ناس عندهم شقق عندهم كذا لا ويقوموا
الكثير من المصريين خاصه في اسوان
باستضافه سودانيين ومساعدتهم بطرق مختلفه
اما في القاهره فتجد منظمات المجتمع نفسها
في حاجه الى تنسيق الجهود مع الدوله
المصريه والسفاره السودانيه لهذا الغرض
وهو ما دفعهم للاجتماع والتشاور لصد العدد
بسيطه يمكن
[موسيقى]
اغلبهم لهم
اقامات في مصر وقرايب في مصر لهم انشطه
يمكن حتى تجاريه في مصر فدول اللي جابهم
بشكل عام وميسرين لسه الازمه لما لما تيجي
المجموعات اكبر من كده على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه يتولى الهلال الاحمر المصري دون
غيره تقديم المساعدات الطبيه للنازحين
الامر الذي يدفع بمنظمات المجتمع المدني
للاتصال بهذه المؤسسه وعرض خدماتها الامور
لازم تبقى مقننه علشان توصل انت عارف في
مثل هذه الاحداث بيحصل ناس مخربين كثير
ونصب كتير وكده فاما يبقى فيه زي ما
بيقولوا
المركب فيها اثنين قبطين بتغرق فما يبيع
فيه هدف واحد ورمز واحد الامور بتبقى اوصل
قرابه الخمسه عشر الف سودانيه دخلوا الى
مصر خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين واستوعبهم
السودانيون المقيمون هنا والمصريون في
اسوان ولكن المخاوف من تزايد الاعداد في
المستقبل تحتاجه للسماح لمنظمات المجتمع
المدني بالدخول على خط المساندات والدعم
تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات